Hello my name is Steve Kofman from
Lin from links uh Today I will talk about
uh the fifth
secret of successful language learning As you
remember the
first secret is to spend enough
time the second is to
do what you want to
do to learn the language the third is to
note what will happen on
language of
the fourth
is the fact
that vocabulary is more important than
grammar fifth fifth is
patience we must have enough
patience to study with patience it is
very very important
not to get upset don't get upset in the
example now I forgot to be upset it
may
be mistakes I don't know it doesn't matter We are
learning things  which we immediately
forget, uh, I listen many times, I don’t
understand, I listen, I read, I eat, and I
look for
the meaning of the vocabulary for the
dictionary, and yet again, I listen, I don’t
understand, and this is always the case, but this is a
process of mistakes or misunderstanding or  I forgot
all of this, this is naturally a normal
part of the process of
learning a language and therefore it is very important
that we do not get upset, we will
continue with patience
uh because it
uh takes time and if we do things
that we like
and we listen to people who Where is the voice We
like and  and yet we make mistakes Uh
we make mistakes it doesn’t matter we must
continue And we we must be sure
that despite all these
uh
mistakes the brain will continue you
know with patience Thank you